President Trump is declaring his support
for Saudi Arabia despite evidence from
his own intelligence community that
Saudi leaders in fact authorized the
killing of Washington Post columnist
Jamal khashoggi in a statement yesterday
he said Saudi Arabia is in his words a
great ally and he refused to condemn the
killing mr. Trump explained the
financial considerations behind his
position it's America first to me it's
all about America first we're not going
to give up hundreds of billions of
dollars in orders in the past the
president has been at odds with
intelligence assessments on Russia and
North Korea we judge Aang is traveling
with the president and West Palm Beach
Florida we do good morning good morning
president Trump is facing increasing
pressure to take tougher measures
against Saudi Arabia but as we heard he
is prioritizing the United States's
economic ties in that statement
yesterday the president wrote we may
never know all the facts surrounding the
murder of mr. Jamal Khashoggi in any
case our relationship is with the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and president
Trump told reporters yesterday oil
prices would quote go through the roof
if the u.s. broke with Saudi Senate
Foreign Relations Committee Chair bob
corker mockingly said the White House is
acting as a public relations firm for
the Saudi Crown Prince GOP senator and
Trump ally Lindsey Graham says it is not
in the US as national interest to look
the other way when it comes to khashoggi
and another Republican Senator Rand Paul
called the president's statements Saudi
Arabia first not America first
bianna and we'll be continuing this
conversation with Michael Morell in our
next hour we just